[Music]
Ang ARA Zuko and genocide this Avatar
scene might have been too graphic for
the animated show but the liveaction
reboot pulls no punches while Netflix's
liveaction reboot of avatar The Last air
bender may be a nostalgic throwback for
fans of the classic Nickelodeon series
much of the bu surrounding the project
concerns how it adapts and reimagines
the source material even if the core
story beats and lore are genuinely kept
intact this new version contains some
pretty major revisions from the original
show such as the temporal element of Ang
and his friend's Journey however
arguably one of the biggest changes of
all comes with the reboots depiction of
a key event from the original series a
scene that was never animated because of
how dark it is in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly Avatar showrunner
Albert Kim revealed that the new series
will depict the fire nation's genocide
of the air Nomad people on screen not
only that but this tragic scene will
serve as the opener of the series The
Air Nomad genocide is one of the most
important events from the world of the
Animated Series highlighting the villain
of the Fire Nation and serving as a
backstory for Ang status as a l of his
people nonetheless the actual event
itself was only ever referenced and not
shown I knew the next Avatar would be
born an air
Nomad so I wiped out the air temples
according to Kim the inclusion of this
harrowing event was a point of priority
for him and the team he told
Entertainment Weekly I felt it was
important that we see the events that
creates the story of Avatar the famous
line is everything changed when the Fire
Nation attacked I wanted to see that
Netflix's avatar the Last air bender
opening with the events of the N Nomad
genocide is a pretty major shift for the
new series but it wasn't just done out
of the creative team's desire to realize
this key plot point on screen throughout
pre-release materials the team has
emphasized the desire to differentiate
the show's identity from what has come
before and including this scene was one
part of demonstrating that shift Kim
told Entertainment Weekly we just wanted
to make sure audiences didn't think they
were getting a kids show we want to
ensure that our show is for all ages if
the world is going to have any chance
it's going to need a nonetheless Kim
clarified that the explicit depiction of
the fire nation's attack on the air
Nomads should not be taken as an
indication that the new version will
simply be a darker and edgier adaptation
instead the team is aiming to recapture
and expand on the mature tone set by
some of the best episodes of avatar in
its later years the show runner went on
for fans of the second and third season
I think it's all in line with what they
saw there on its face a live action
avatar the Last air bender featuring The
demise of the air Nomads at the hands of
the Fire Nation seems to be a pretty
solid indication that the new series
won't be pulling punches with its
depiction of events and characters from
The Source material nonetheless the news
of the scene's inclusion comes amid a
bit of controversy that suggest the
opposite specifically the Netflix
adaptation has made a huge change to
Saka Arc that has fans div Ed the team
revealed to Entertainment Weekly that
they decided to tone down Saka sexist
qualities in the new series guaro actor
go and Dio said I feel like there were a
lot of moments on the original show that
were iffy girls are better at fixing
pants than guys and guys are better at
hunting and fighting and stuff like that
it's just the natural order of things
the news sparked a substantial backlash
from the original Show's fan base many
of whom argue that Sara's growth Beyond
his traditionalist perspective is a
major part of his character Arc some
even accus a reboot of sanding down the
edges of the original series presumably
in a misguided attempt to make it more
palatable to General audiences it's
worth noting that Netflix's version of
avatar The Last Air vender is officially
rated tv14 meaning that it's primarily
targeting an older audience than the
original animated series which landed a
TV y7 rating while the controversy
regarding the shows perceiv sanitizing
of Sara's character flaws and the news
that the show will feature more graphic
content appear to be a Todds it remains
be seen how General viewers react to the
new Show's handling of the franchise's
more mature themes when it
[Music]
releases